[Musique]
c'est le terrain de l'école buissonnière
c'est une école maternelle alternative
dans les bois on accueille les enfants
de l'île de Ré dans la nature
notre salle de classe ce sera vraiment
100% à l'extérieur
j'adore sauter dans les flaques c'est
quoi
j'aime bien l'eau de la mer
je m'appelle Mao
[Musique]
je suis professeur des écoles comme
avant mais à l'extérieur
[Musique]
de donner un peu la liberté quand même
aux enfants et donc ne pas les cadrer
surtout à l'âge petit parce que sinon on
est cadré notre vie après
un concept qu'on aime le rapprochement à
la nature
[Musique]
j'espère vraiment que c'est une
pédagogie d'avenir parce que les enfants
sont soumis à la télévision plein de
choses et ils en oublient un petit peu
leur environnement et la nature et tout
ce que ça peut leur apporter
[Musique]
moi je m'appelle Oliver
vrai vous demandez de faire un tunnel de
par deux pour que les enfants puissent
passer en dessous
afin d'entrer définitivement dans
l'école buissonnière
le symboliquement les enfants qui
passent sous le pont ils font partie
maintenant de la grande famille de
l'école buissonnière
sa réponse très certainement à des
enjeux futurs évidemment que d'avoir des
enfants qui se soucient de la planète
c'est tout ce qu'on peut souhaiter
maintenant est-ce que ça répond à tous
les enjeux éducatifs est-ce que ce
modèle d'école permet tous les types
d'apprentissage ça pose d'autres
questions en fait
[Musique]
parce que tu veux
dire bonjour
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est un concept que je connais de mon
pays natal l'Allemagne et qui a fait ses
preuves d'ailleurs dans plein d'autres
pays dans les années 60 et a eu les
premiers à jardins d'enfants en forêt en
Allemagne c'est à cette époque là où
vraiment la pédagogie par la nature est
né et qu'on a découvert tous les
bienfaits de cette pédagogie donc à nous
de voir maintenant si ça marche aussi
avec les enfants de l'île de Ré tu veux
demander aux autres
est-ce que vous avez entendu la
tourterelle qui a chanté avec nous
et est-ce que vous vous rappelez de nos
noms à nous c'est qui cette dame en face
Marguerite
[Musique]
à partir d'aujourd'hui nous allons tous
les jours d'école écrire la date hier
nous avons fait la fête ensemble on
était mercredi est-ce que vous savez
quel jour il y a après le mercredi
Mao est-ce que tu sais quel jour il y a
après le mercredi quel jour sommes-nous
aujourd'hui
je dis bravo timel
on s'arrête qu'est-ce qu'on a dit après
vite
non
le 9 le 9 aujourd'hui nous sommes jeudi
comment est-ce que je peux écrire
septembre
quel animal fait ce son
le serpent serpent et le serpent
c'est une note qui ressemble au serpent
qui se tortille
tout à fait
je vais vous montrer toutes les lettres
que j'ai
[Musique]
pas peur la première école de la forêt a
été créée il y a 3 ans à Angoulême le
covid a énormément aidé puisque tous les
politiciens incitent les instits à
sortir de plus en plus avec leurs
enfants on arrive vraiment au bon moment
on va dire
capucine tu veux venir
en Allemagne à peu près 2000 forêts au
Danemark les écoles maternelles en
extérieur représente 20% de l'ensemble
des écoles maternelles et en France
aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore parvenus
à ce niveau là en fait à la fois dans
les consciences et dans la pratique
néanmoins on peut se féliciter d'une
chose c'est que depuis 2019 les
différents confinements il y a eu un
engouement absolument
extraordinaire sur le sujet
[Rires]
au revoir et les moutons faut sortir
un peu de votre bergerie aussi
on est la base de la pédagogie par la
nature c'est le jeu libre c'est insiste
sur le fait que les enfants sont
capables d'apprendre énormément de
choses par eux-mêmes et des uns des
autres je les regarde jouer je repère
des compétences du programme qui te
mettent en oeuvre sans s'en rendre
compte et ensuite je leur propose un jeu
qui reprend cette compétence le but du
jeu c'est de leur faire prendre
conscience de ce qu'ils mettent déjà en
oeuvre tout seul en fait as-tu trouvé
des bandits
[Musique]
et moi tu viens à l'école
maintenant on est là non
on est dans le canapé
en jouet là c'est le canapé
forestier joue et après
l'heure des parents
et d'un coup on sort du tas de feuilles
qu'on veut et les autres ils font une
ronde autour de nous et l'hérissons il
doit essayer de nous attraper
elle me parle beaucoup de l'école elle
me dit que les maîtresses ne crient pas
elle apprécie aussi beaucoup le fait
qu'il soit en petit groupe et je pense
que le mélange d'âge est intéressant
puisque les petits apprennent des grands
et les grands bah voilà développent des
compétences d'entraide parce que ils
aident les plus petits
mon objectif c'est de dire à Mao qu'on a
pas nécessairement besoin d'être entre
quatre murs et dans une salle de classe
assis sur une chaise avec un crayon pour
apprendre et qu'on peut aussi apprendre
de la nature sans forcément jouer avec
des jouets en plastique là on peut
apprendre à compter avec des marrons on
peut peindre des feuilles ça leur
apprend un petit peu le manque de
confort aussi
on peut se parler
on peut disputer
et là on a des idées non pas disputer
on discutait
on discute on a des idées
[Musique]
c'est quoi le jeu du hérisson
du modèle scandinave dans ces pays en
fait la vie en plein air est vraiment
quelque chose d'important il y a une
connexion presque naturelle de l'homme
avec la nature et un principe aussi
philosophique spirituel tous ces
principes là sont pas forcément
transposables dans notre pays il faut
tenir compte de la culture tu veux
choisir une chanson Mao
oui ça va vous planter les pommiers
à la mode à la mode savez-vous
quelle est la première lettre de ton
prénom
le M est-ce que tu saurais le
reconnaître
[Musique]
effectivement Mao n'a pas reconnu son
prénom dans les autres étiquettes parce
que aujourd'hui on a mis l'écriture en
attaché
comme les enfants de l'école
buissonnière sont d'âge et de niveau
différents il y a les lettres que l'on
apprend d'abord à écrire et qui sont
simples à écrire parce qu'elles sont en
capital imprimerie ensuite tu as celle
qui sert à apprendre à lire
avec une majuscule et les minuscules et
ensuite il y a les lettres en attaché
pour apprendre à écrire
[Musique]
on appuie sur le bout de bois après
c'est bon
et ça suffit maintenant
allez on va dans la cabane
accroché à la corde de la charrette du
patron va dans les bois
allez on y va les enfants
ils apprennent le monde du vivant déjà
c'est extraordinaire de découvrir par
soi-même et pas de le lire dans les
livres comme on le fait souvent à
l'école j'ai trouvé une pomme de pain
avec des gens avec des champignons aussi
venez se trouver d'autres gens de mieux
quand vous voyez des champignons comme
ça dans les bois il faut surtout pas les
toucher pourquoi il faut pas les toucher
[Musique]
est-ce que ce sont des champignons qui
se mangent ou est-ce que ce sont des
champignons dangereux et après ça
ma maison et oui il faut se laver les
mains après
une école par la nature c'est vraiment
pour les sensibiliser à l'écologie au
respect de la nature au respect d'être
vivant on espère que ils auront cette
cette intérêt pour la nature que que on
a un petit peu oublié et du moins c'est
ce que j'ai envie de leur donner
[Musique]
surtout des escargots
ils viennent s'inviter sur les buissons
alors ça c'est la combinaison
indispensable pour aller dans les marais
parce que sinon on se mouille c'est une
salopette qui permet aux enfants de
rester au sec et de pouvoir sauter dans
les flaques et faire tout ce qu'ils
veulent
super
- 50 et on était heureux d'être dehors à
moins 5 ans on devait se couvrir parce
que je sais pas si vous savez mais on
peut pas respirer le nez il devient
blanc et voilà c'est ça gèle mais on ne
voulait sortir même un moment sympa
[Musique]
dans la pédagogie par la nature le plus
important bien évidemment c'est d'être
dans un lieu naturel qui doit être
inspirant c'est à dire que non seulement
on est en nature mais en plus on a
autour de soi énormément de matériaux
naturels la deuxième chose c'est la
récurrence le temps long il y a une idée
de répétition et d'évolution de la
nature autour de soi de vraiment se
sentir dans l'environnement qui évolue
et c'est d'évoluer avec lui
nous sommes arrivés dans les marais et
tout à l'heure Mao me disait mais il y a
pas d'animaux ici
plein dans les bassins et à l'extérieur
pour les animaux qui sont dans les
bassins pour rien jeter dans les bassins
parce que c'est comme si vous on vous
lança quelque chose sur la tête
[Musique]
et celle là par exemple moi je vais la
remettre à l'eau est-ce que vous voyez
une différence
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres qui veulent
mettre des crevettes à l'eau
[Musique]
uniquement quand il est il se sent en
danger c'est pour se protéger
nous avons fait un petit tour dans les
marais pour découvrir l'environnement
proche de l'école
nous avons découvert les gambas les
huîtres et puis de plantes très
particulières d'ici le Bienne et la
salicorne et donc voilà tout ça sont des
produits typiquement retaient et
apparemment les enfants apprécient bien
les huîtres Arthur est-ce que je peux en
avoir une s'il te plaît
merci
pédagogique là ça resserre les liens du
groupe on découvre aussi l'environnement
proche et ça c'est très important il y a
pas grand chose qui leur fait peur ils
sont très férus de nouvelles découvertes
j'ai l'impression merci ma
tu sais comment ça s'appelle
un ancrage de l'enfant à son
environnement à son écosystème
chaque action que l'on mène un déchet et
ben ça a une répercussion le fait qu'on
fasse brûler quelque chose ça fait des
nuages de la pluie et je me dis qu'on y
est on plongée on peut mieux se rendre
compte de ça même si on veut la balise
pas forcément mais
rien qu'à voir l'attrait pour la nature
pour l'environnement est-ce que ça peut
créer chez ce groupe d'enfants la joie
de vivre dehors en communauté pour moi
ça veut juste dire que la clé elle est
ici quoi
[Musique]
la pêche est un terrain de jeu
intéressant parce que d'un point de vue
moteur elle développe des choses très
différentes d'un terrain plat les
rochers sont glissants le sable rajoute
encore les possibilités de lisserdre et
puis voilà des possibilités de
découverte naturelle infinies avec des
questionnements très pragmatiques
qu'est-ce que c'est Comment ça pousse
moi il pense pas il bouge pas il faut le
mettre dans l'eau
c'est un crabe qu'on va remettre à l'eau
c'est une observation directe d'éléments
naturels qu'on ne voit pas forcément
tous les jours là ils sont beaucoup plus
attentifs à leur environnement parce
qu'on n'est pas à l'école
on va pas s'aventurer trop dans l'eau
capucine parce que tu vas avoir des
chaussettes tout mouillés
est-ce que tu veux goûter la poire salée
pour moi
c'est bon
il y a énormément d'entre elles qui
s'est installées entre eux quand il y a
un truc lourd à porter genre un grand
tronc d'arbre on peut pas le porter tout
seul donc on a besoin de ses copains
pour le porter
quand ils ont envie de crier c'est pas
un problème c'est vraiment un endroit où
ils ont beaucoup de liberté même si nous
on doit on a des règles bien sûr à
respecter pour pas les mettre en danger
le risque quand on regarde les pays
anglo-saxons il est valorisé c'est
important que les enfants prennent des
risques faute de quoi en fait ils sont
pas autonomes ensuite il y a les dangers
c'est des risques auxquels s'exposent
les enfants mais qui peuvent pas
anticiper
à l'épreuve dans une activité motrice
qui représente un risque ça va lui
permettre de prendre confiance en lui il
est obligé de faire attention pour
maintenir sa sécurité donc la
concentration est aussi bien plus
importante que sur une activité motrice
classique
où est-ce qu'elle doit être la si par
rapport à tes mains
est-ce qu'elle doit être prêt ou loin de
tes doigts
loin de tes doigts et si moi je reste
comme ça à côté de toi est-ce que ça te
va
pourquoi
[Musique]
on fait pour savoir si quelqu'un est
dans sa bulle ou pas
avec ton bras fais le tour je suis
encore un petit peu près
on n'essaye pas de surproté les enfants
on essaye au contraire de leur laisser
découvrir leurs limites et pour ça il
faut prendre des risques
[Musique]
Chanel regarde il y a Chris qui est en
train de scier et qui a besoin que tu
t'éloignes un peu qu'est-ce que tu sais
tu peux le dire avec des mots aussi
maintenant que
je prends
des enfants ils voient des petits
insectes dans les bois il s'intéresse à
cet animal ils vont être face à face au
monde vivant et ils vont se sentir
beaucoup plus proche aussi du coup et il
le protège après
de le suivre
voilà il est sous une feuille
on va regarder dans le livre de quelle
famille il est alors après il va oui au
capucine bah parce qu'il est libre lui
aussi j'ai apporté un livre pour
regarder ce que c'est alors regardez
avec Caroline
je pense
ça ressemble pas ça c'est pas aussi long
Chris c'est le mâle et la femelle
mais avec des pipi ce que j'ai pu lire
en fait c'est surtout que cette
répétition régulière de contact avec la
nature permettait à l'enfant de se
sentir un peu comme chez lui de
développer une connexion intime en fait
avec la nature et cette proximité créée
fait que il doit envie d'y retourner il
revient prendre soin et même quand il
serait adulte
on estime que en France quatre enfants
sur 10 ne jouent pas en extérieur de
toute la semaine ce manque de nature il
se traduit par un certain nombre de
troubles physiques et psychologiques une
absence d'équilibre une baisse des
performances cardio-vasculaires un
déficit de vision
se constat-là on le retrouve dans des
rapports de l'éducation nationale qui
attestent du fait que les enfants
souffrent de façon croissante de ce type
de trouble
[Musique]
alors on est exactement à la moitié de
l'année scolaire nous avons 11 enfants
inscrits à l'école buissonnière la
classe a un petit peu évolué puisqu'on a
un enfant qui est parti un autre qui est
arrivé et puis comme dans n'importe
quelle école il y a bien sûr des
déménagements des gens qui viennent
d'arriver dans la région
[Musique]
[Rires]
qui sont différents il y a la plage
là-bas et la forêt elle est juste là-bas
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup ici
nous avons un système de toilette sèche
qui permet que les enfants puissent
aller aux toilettes quand ils en ont
envie
[Applaudissements]
il y a une petite cloche accrochée à la
paroi qui permet de nous appeler s'ils
ont besoin de nous et ensuite c'est
Caroline ou moi qui vit donc le saut de
compost dans un de nos composteurs et
nous avons aussi un compost pour nos
déchets alimentaires et tous les jours
il y a un enfant qui est responsable du
compost on va l'utiliser ensuite pour
créer notre jardin donc ça prendra son
sens à ce moment là
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça montre pas sur le
visage qu'est-ce que vous sentez
de l'eau de la pluie
ce sont des grosses gouttes ou des
petites gouttes
et regardez par terre est-ce que vous
voyez les petites gouttelettes sur les
feux sur les herbes
[Musique]
quelque chose et on voit les petites
gouttes est-ce que tout le monde voit
pourquoi est-ce qu'on les voit si bien
il y a de la pluie sur
[Musique]
combien est-ce qu'on a de kiwis là
alors combien est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire de couronne dans ces trois kiwis 2
et là 2 6 et là 6 parce que trois fois
deux couronnes pas toutes ça fait 6 mois
parce que je pense que si Maya d'ici
c'est parce qu'il voulait une couronne
tu en veux une couronne aussi
vous pouvez commencer à compter
[Musique]
et les voilà percées
monter à l'arbre c'est vraiment la base
il y a beaucoup d'enfants qui au début
ont peur de la hauteur
petit à petit on monte sur la première
branche on sent sécurité on l'a fait une
fois deux fois on va le refaire avec ou
sans aide
[Musique]
que j'ai observé c'est que la plupart au
bout d'un moment se sentent quand même
relativement à l'aise ils prennent leur
Mac à partir du moment où
ils arrivent à se faire confiance
certains enfants peuvent rester
craintifs et avoir besoin de repères
humains trouver que c'est trop grand
voilà ils sont lits de faire ce qu'ils
veulent ils sont même de choisir les
activités qui veulent et c'est pas tous
les jours qu'on leur dit ça
on les a pas amenés vers quelque chose
ils ont tous progressé à partir de leur
personnalité propre chacun a développé
sa personnalité et s'extraverti de plus
en plus mais en partant de de soi
[Musique]
bonjour Julie bonjour capucine il est où
Arthur
[Musique]
au revoir Belly bonne journée les grands
[Rires]
il fait super froid mais il y a du grand
soleil et il y a pas mal de vent mais il
est nord-est donc ça va faire comme
l'autre jour où on sera protégé par la
lune tu sais ils avaient fait le site
spot au soleil c'était le coup la marée
elle est où à midi 12h30 bah ouais c'est
parfait elle est en train de monter
c'est un petit coef donc c'est parfait
alors est-ce que il y a quelqu'un qui
sait pour quelle saison nous sommes
arrivés ce matin dis donc
je me réveiller ce matin comment on
reconnaît que c'est l'hiver
[Musique]
comment on reconnaît que c'est le
l'hiver
il fait froid alors on a notre
thermomètre ici on va regarder quelle
température il fait tu vois où il
s'arrête le trait rouge
zéro au zéro et donc combien est-ce
qu'il fait aujourd'hui
[Musique]
un peu plus
depuis le mois de septembre on a eu une
météo assez clémente par contre l'hiver
est quand même bien rude les parents
jouent super bien le jeu
on n'a pas à leur précisé comment il
faut habiller les enfants c'était
l'heure appréhension il n'y a pas de
mauvais temps que des mauvaises habits
donc les enfants à aucun moment ils se
plaignent là où il y a des trous Arthur
on recule
on s'assoit
alors on a encore un petit peu de temps
et on va faire du yoga on inspire par le
nez
et on fait le lion avec la bouche
[Musique]
l'éléphant donne un grand coup dans le
fruit et l'envoient
et enfin de l'ours fruits fondé ses bras
à cette moitié d'année on a fait une
petite réunion avec les parents pour
faire un petit bilan et un de retour
c'était l'apaisement ils ont trouvé
leurs enfants apaisés moins fatigués que
lorsqu'il rentrait d'une école classique
alors qu'on est un peu en activité tout
le temps mais en fait il n'y a pas de
pression ni des enseignantes ni des
enfants ni du groupe
la mettre à la poubelle
c'est sûr que au début on avait des
appréhensions quand on a entendu parler
de cette école notamment par rapport au
fait que l'enfant reste dehors toute la
journée on s'est rendu compte que
finalement c'est tellement bénéfique
pour l'enfant d'être dehors que
il y a plus tout ce bruit dans les
classes qui les fatigue d'être dehors
ils apprennent la vie finalement ça va
les construire maintenant mais c'est
pour plus tard aussi et c'est ça qui est
chouette
c'est le sucre
[Musique]
le moment du canapé forestier du matin
est à un moment important pour lequel on
essaie d'avoir tous les enfants mais on
va pas traîner un enfant contre sa
volonté d'imaël claque des difficultés
d'éveil le matin et donc il a besoin
d'un temps parfois plus long que les
autres si on le force à participer à ce
moment-là il va se sentir mal pour le
reste de la journée donc c'est
contre-productif quand on va partir on
espère qu'il sera motivé pour la suite
de la journée
[Musique]
et ensuite
si ça marche pas ça marche pas mais
c'est pas grave on essaie
[Musique]
je comprends que on casse pas les
cabanes si je vous dis le mot art les
enfants qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque
est-ce que vous êtes déjà allé dans un
musée voir de l'art non non
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu un tableau
oui
est-ce que là c'est un carré
qui sont plus longs pour que ça fasse un
rectangle il faut que les bâtons qui
sont de la même longueur soit opposés
les uns aux autres ça c'est un truc
temps ok
aujourd'hui on va utiliser les éléments
de la nature pour faire une œuvre d'art
un carré alors il faut trouver quatre
bâtons de la même longueur c'est
difficile
on finit de l'école à 14h il nous manque
quand même pas mal d'heures par rapport
à une école classique et en fait on
n'est pas en retard sur le programme les
compétences qui ont été acquises par les
enfants sont bien ancrés le fait de
partir de leur motivation ça change tout
s'ils sont en train de faire autre chose
on va laisser tomber notre programme et
on va se saisir de ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire et pousser les
compétences mises en œuvre dans ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire
c'est d'une telle efficacité que
vraiment c'est dommage de faire
autrement
il faudrait les mettre à l'endroit
[Musique]
l'attente c'était surtout qui s'éclate
qui vivent sa vie d'enfant après en
autonomie et il a énormément
pris tellement pris que des fois c'est
même on se dit ben non c'est pas
possible tu peux pas faire des choses
comme ça il veut prendre son vélo aller
se promener tout seul il veut vivre tout
seul autonomie complète quoi et il
demande par contre maintenant
aller dans une école
normale entre guillemets je pense qu'il
a envie d'apprendre d'autres choses mais
je sens qu'il est plus près
moi je mets les pieds dans l'eau même
quand il fait pas bon et je saute comme
les crapauds les pieds dans l'eau je
trouve ça très rigolo
bonjour
ça va
[Applaudissements]
contrairement à l'année dernière où
l'hiver avait été très rude cette année
on a vraiment eu de la chance on a eu
trois jours de pluie depuis le début de
l'année il nous demande souvent de
mettre la bâche qui nous sert à nous
protéger quand il y a de la pluie et
donc je pense que ils aiment la pluie et
qu'ils aimeraient qu'on ait plus on fait
exactement les mêmes choses que
d'habitude mais dans cet espace là et
assez rapidement les enfants nous
demandent de sortir de cet espace et
donc on retourne jouer sous la pluie
[Musique]
à la mer avec les autres
avec la tempête de chez les en tant
qu'enseignante on nous dit que le
cerveau des enfants est programmé pour
apprendre et pour être curieux et en
fait on l'oublie et quand j'ai vu la
curiosité que les plus jeunes avaient
vis-à-vis de compétences que les grands
mettaient en œuvre j'étais super
impressionnée de la rapidité et de
l'efficacité des échanges mais regarde
il est là l'accent
exactement si cet accent qui va t'aider
à le retrouver
les pieds dans l'eau les mains dans
l'eau les femmes
je trouve pas ça
[Musique]
au développement de l'apprentissage en
extérieur en France qui est lieu fait
que plus les enfants sortent plus ils se
salissent beaucoup de parents ne
souhaitent pas clore enfants reviennent
salle tous les soirs et donc un travail
d'aculturation des parents à cette forme
d'apprentissage il doit entendre que
c'est utile pour leurs enfants
fatigués un peu fatigué bah oui j'ai vu
comment tu as sauté dans les flaques
je crois que Mao on va changer les
chaussures dehors il paraît qu'il y a de
l'eau dans les bottes
oh là là t'as vraiment fait comme les
grenouilles là et toi tu as aimé les
flaques oui la grande flaque de
alors regardez dehors quel temps il fait
il pleut encore ou pas
[Musique]
surpris dans son sommeil piticoque ne
peut voler au secours des pauvres
poulettes terrorisés
[Applaudissements]
on va utiliser des œufs aujourd'hui le
plus simple c'est d'en mettre un ou deux
mais faut pas en mettre trop et après il
faut très très bien serré
je pourrais en fait avoir un petit œuf
[Musique]
jaune
voici les deux œufs qui étaient dans les
pelures d'oignons de quelle couleur
est-ce qu'ils sont ils sont marrons et
cela
ouais c'est un petit peu bleuté un petit
peu violet ça c'est ce qui était dans le
chou rouge on va les remettre parce
qu'on va laisser bien plus longtemps que
ça
on peut la manger
[Musique]
vous pouvez récupérer vos noms
on va essayer peut-être qu'il va trouver
tout seul alors Maé
bravo Maé
bravo vous m'entendez la tourterelle
vous essayez de parler avec elle
qui est Simon
était encore au lit
Caroline la première année elle a fait
comme un prix d'appel tarif vraiment
abordable pour tout le monde je dirais
c'était intéressant là c'est vrai que
pour la survie de l'école et bah aussi
pour qu'elle puisse se verser un salaire
elle risque d'augmenter les tarifs c'est
une instruction individualisée c'est une
instruction particulière donc c'est vrai
que c'est un coût et pour mon mari pour
quelqu'un qui est moins sensible à ce
genre d'école ça peut être un frein
quand j'ai créé l'école j'avais pas
envie d'avoir une école que pour les
riches pour moi c'était vraiment
important d'avoir un prix abordable pour
tout le monde donc j'ai fixé un prix à
275 euros sur 10 mois on rentre pas trop
dans nos frais l'année prochaine on va
faire trois différents tarifs selon le
quotient familial ça va aller de 200 à
260 euros
au fur et à mesure que ces écoles
gagnants en expérience et en maturité
elle gagne également visibilité et donc
le modèle économique il est équilibré ce
qui veut pas pour autant dire qu'il est
pas fragile
[Musique]
c'est un modèle qui est très inspirant
après c'est pas un modèle qui est encore
accessible à tous on a un environnement
qui est extraordinaire on a des
disponibilités qui font qu'on peut
récupérer capuciner 14 heures donc je
sais pas si c'est vraiment le modèle
d'avenir aujourd'hui il y a plein de
modèles pédagogiques qui existent et qui
sont aussi tout inspirants je pense que
ce qu'il faudrait c'est surtout laisser
plus de liberté de créativité aux
enseignants et d'action pour leur faire
confiance et qui puisse mettre aussi des
choses en place
dans tous les sens
avec moi ça fait trois fois que je te
laisse c'est stop
merci de ne pas commencer à te jeter
dessus on va regarder d'abord qu'est-ce
que vous voyez devant vous
des noix de cajou qu'est-ce que vous
regardez
un marron
une graine j'ai trouvé quelque chose
qui se mange qu'est-ce que c'est est-ce
que tu sais le reconnaître peut-être
alors des noisettes
du café alors toutes ces choses qui se
mangent elles ont quelque chose d'autre
de particulier de très important
exactement à l'intérieur il y a une
amende que l'on peut manger en fait
toutes ces parties là toutes ces choses
qu'on mange devant nous ce sont des
graines
il y a des
qu'est-ce qu'on a planté vous rappelez
des tomates
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils en soif
ces plantes
faudrait leur donner à boire alors
chacun a développé des compétences qui
sont un petit peu différentes les unes
des autres ils ont énormément développé
leur motricité ils ont tous acquis un
niveau d'autonomie incroyable au niveau
du langage aussi on a des longs moments
d'échanges verbaux qui font que en terme
de langage ils ont vraiment bien
progressé
[Musique]
bien sûr que tu peux goûter déjà
ça pique
la taupe creuse de l'ombre galerie et
passe presque toute sa vie sous terre
les vers de terre sortent la nuit pour
manger leur galerie AR le sol de la
forêt sans ces petits animaux la forêt
ne pourraient pas vivre
[Musique]
qui est là c'est qui
quelque part pour pour moi en tant que
maman ce qui importe c'est pas
spécialement qu'il soit dans une école
dans les Bobois ou voilà c'est que quand
il se retrouve maintenant dans un groupe
ils sont en autonomie et en capacité de
sentir où est quelque part leur place et
où est-ce qu'il se sente bien et
d'interagir naturellement avec les
autres
vendre eux
dis pour écrire dit qu'est-ce qu'il nous
faut comme lettre
hier nous étions le 12 donc aujourd'hui
on est le combien tu peux recompter
depuis le début si tu veux
[Musique]
13 13 exactement je vais écrire tout le
mot parce que c'est un petit mot et je
te laisse écrire ensuite les lettres
toutes les unes après les autres OK
la dernière chose qu'on n'avait pas
encore énormément travaillé qui était
l'écriture qu'on a commencé tardivement
puisqu'on l'a commencé en fait au moment
où ils en ont exprimé l'envie et ben là
ça y est les plus grands sont entrées
dans les trois écritures et tout le
monde participe
plusieurs études montrent que de fait
non seulement ils ont une plus grande
capacité à se concentrer en Angleterre
qui est l'équivalent en fait de nos
inspecteurs de l'éducation nationale
donne des mentions excellentes qui
viennent acter que cette approche
pédagogique est extrêmement efficace
pour suivre le programme
oui on va accueillir nos acacias qu'on
va tout mettre dans le téléphone
[Musique]
derrière
il neige quand on se promène elle me
décrit le nom des fleurs et elle connaît
maintenant plus de fleurs que moi donc
c'est elle qui m'apprend le nom de
certaines fleurs je me suis dit si jeune
à trois ans je pensais pas que ce serait
déjà elle qui m'apprendrai des choses
quoi donc je suis fière
socialement je la trouve beaucoup plus
apaisée dans son rapport aux autres mais
aussi elle arrive mieux à gérer ses
émotions je le vois quand on est en
sortie dans les bois par exemple avant
que c'est moi qui avait tendance à aller
la stimuler l'orienter dans ses
explorations là maintenant elle va
découvrir par elle-même elle va les
toucher elle va les sentir il y a plus
d'appréhension elle est vraiment à
l'aise
à l'éducation nationale c'est destin
Freinet il parlait déjà de mettre les
enfants contact de la nature aussi avec
le dernier le mouvement est assez lent à
se mettre en place les enseignants
manquent de formation il manque d'outils
pour communiquer aux parents sur les
bienfaits de cette pédagogie mais depuis
le covid on voit quand même qu'il y a
une grosse accélération de cette envie
là et maintenant même sur les sites de
circonscription de l'Académie on trouve
des séquences et des séances toutes
faites clé en main pour emmener les
enfants en extérieur et Diego ça fait
quelle couleur
regarde moi je prends toujours
[Musique]
on différencie souvent les savoir-faire
et les savoir-être c'est sans doute dans
les savoirs-être que les progrès sont
les plus impressionnants c'est plus
facile pour un enfant de cet âge-là de
percevoir qu'il a confiance en lui
plutôt que de se rendre compte que d'un
seul coup il sait compter alors qu'avant
il ne le savait pas c'est savoir être
qu'ils ont développé à l'école
buissonnière ça fonde leur amour propre
leur résilience et c'est ce qui va leur
permettre d'aller plus loin dans les
apprentissages autres dans les savoirs
fer classique
j'ai écrasé les fleurs on va avoir des
pro-éducation publique on va avoir des
pros pédagogiques et ça ça va être
clivant à un moment donné ce sujet là il
part des besoins de l'enfant et il est
de dire cette approche elle est
désirable la vocation à se développer
partout en ville et en campagne et en
priorisé dans les banlieues de favoriser
il y a de nouveaux enfants qui vont
arriver à l'école vous le savez
[Musique]
je crois qu'il y a marqué Maé dessus
c'est pour toi
créer sa propre structure c'était un peu
l'aventure fallait allier tout ce qui
est travail pédagogique tout en
travaillant avec les points clés de la
pédagogie par la nature et d'un autre
côté beaucoup d'émotion aussi parce que
on s'attache forcément aux enfants et
pendant deux mois ne plus voir
capucine qui rigole Christ qui raconte
ses petites histoires Arthur qui prend
dans les bras j'appréhende comment ça va
se passer à lundi quand je vais pas
aller à l'école quoi
[Musique]
au revoir